. There's a very interesting axios report
that shows our friend Bernie Sanders understands
they can't count on Republicans for a damn
thing and that he plans to push covid relief
and maybe more through the Senate with a simple
majority.
He was on CNN's State of the Union yesterday
talking about this, and he said they'll see
about other issues with the covid relief package
proposed by Joe Biden, which will top up the
600 dollar payments to 2000 with an additional
fourteen hundred dollars and expand unemployment
benefits and do a lot of other things.
Bernie Sanders says it will be a simple majority
vote in the Senate to get it through.
Why is this so important?
This process, known as budget reconciliation,
allows Democrats to skip or circumvent the
60 vote requirement that exists in the Senate
for many, many legislative attempts, for many
bills.
And if Democrats are able to use budget reconciliation
to rather than need 60 votes in the Senate,
which means you've got to find 10 Republican
votes, 50 with Kamala Harris is a tie breaking
vote would be enough to get benefits to unemployed
Americans to bolster unemployment benefits
to get that additional fourteen hundred dollar
payment.
And what Bernie Sanders is saying is really
clear, really pragmatic.
And I love to see him saying this.
Bernie says, quote, What we cannot do is wait
weeks and weeks and months to go forward.
We have to act now.
We are going to use reconciliation.
That's 50 votes in the Senate, plus the vice
president to pass this legislation.
And when he was asked if he wants a relief
bill passed before Trump's impeachment trial
begins in just a couple of weeks, he said,
we've got to do everything.
This is not you don't have time to sit around
weeks on impeachment and not get vaccines
into the arms of people, referring, of course,
to the additional vaccine funding in the coronavirus
stimulus.
I think that this is absolutely the right
thing to do.
You don't have to.
I mean, listen, we're going to be having the
conversation about the filibuster soon on
the show.
And I've been reading a lot about it.
Many of you have been saying talk about getting
rid of the filibuster or not.
Aside from that, not only may Democrats have
to do this, Democrats will have to do this
on a number of issues over the next couple
of years, they have until the 2022 midterms
to show what it means to have a Democratic
majority and what can be done with it if they
waste it by letting the Republican Party poison
the well on everything they want to do and
obstruct the way we know Republicans are planning
to do, it will actually make the case for
giving Democrats more seats in 22.
Very difficult to make.
Wait a second.
You had the House, Senate and White House
and you didn't get anything done?
Well, we needed 60.
Well, but you could have used budget reconciliation
to get it done with a simple majority.
Right.
But now it these are unique times coming off
of arguably the worst presidency in modern
American history during a mishandled global
hundred year pandemic with an economic layer
on top of the medical layer.
If there is ever a time to say, guys, you
know, you you, Marjorie Taylor Greens and
Lauren Bowerbirds, Ted Cruz and all these
guys who are who are still raising money from
these wacko cultists, trumpet's, we just can't
even deal with you guys.
We're going to get things done on our own.
And that's how ultimately Democrats will have
to justify reelection in November of twenty
two.
This is the idea of getting rid of the filibuster.
This is why Mitch McConnell is fighting it,
because they want to do anything they can
to prevent Democrats from being able to pass
things with a simple majority budget.
Reconciliation is a way that they could do
covid relief without getting 60 votes now
on the filibuster.
There are arguments on both sides.
If I if I'm sort of previewing my most recent
thought, I'm leaning towards being supportive
of getting rid of the filibuster.
That's not what this conversation is about.
This conversation is about passing covid relief
quickly.
I'm talking in the next 10 to 14 days without
a 60 vote majority using budget reconciliation.
Now, it's important to remember budgets can't
be filibustered.
Anything that is allocations of money or lack
thereof can be passed without zero Republican
votes.
There are other things where, as of right
now, Republicans can filibuster.
If Democrats decide we're going to do this
with a simple majority, Republicans can't
stop them.
I believe this is the right decision.
I'm glad to see Bernie in this position.
And I want to hear from you.
Where do you think this is going to lead during
the next two years?
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman,